you've surveyed some of your members
doctors working on the front line in the
fight against Cove at 19 what have they
been telling you they've been telling us
that they're extremely worried stressed
anxious some complaining about burnout
forty five percent of doctors feel this
way and remember they're working in
unimaginably challenging situations
where they're there looking after
patients in hospitals that have been
turned around into coded centers
essentially patients who don't have
visitors they're looking after deaths at
a level they've never experienced before
often as I said spending time with with
patients at the end of their lives
without their loved ones but even more
stressful now is that doctors and other
health care workers are treating their
own colleagues in intensive care on
ventilators and tragically seeing some
of them not survive this is extremely
emotionally taxing physically taxing and
it's showing its toll on the healthcare
workforce it's certainly an incredibly
difficult time for those people on the
front line of this battle as many people
put it are there any specific examples
that have stood out to you to really
illustrate to us what's happening I mean
one of the immediate issues and you've
been discussing this on the program is
that doctors are extremely afraid that
they are not adequately protected now
this is completely understandable this
is a highly contagious virus doctors are
looking after patients extremely close
proximity inches away sometimes we know
that that about 50% of doctors are
telling us that they don't feel they
have the adequate protection to prevent
them getting infected but that's
extremely scary for any healthcare
worker and remember this isn't about
just being concerned about one's own
personal health because if you become
infected it can take a week before you
develop symptoms that you may spread
that infection to other patients there
are documented examples where doctors
who've been infected have infected many
others within their healthcare community
and patients so this is a serious fear
issue in terms of even controlling
spread and preventing deaths we heard
from Michael Geary Valley on the program
who was talking about more protective
equipment being on its way clearly it's
a Herculean effort to get this amount of
protective equipment to the frontline as
the house secretary said but there have
also been stories or warnings if you
like that some hospitals and some areas
of the country could be running out
within days what is the reality we want
the government last weekend that there
were critically low shortages of full
sleeve gowns so they have notice of this
problem because as the BMA we have
reports from doctors across the UK but
what's really sort of frustrating and
remember our survey also showed that 51
percent of doctors don't feel looked
after by the government they don't feel
confident of being supported because at
the beginning of this pandemic we were
assured that the UK had sufficient
stockpiles you remember those
announcements being made and we believed
that we were well catered for we then
heard that the issues were not about the
stockpile but about operational
deliveries and we heard some apologies
that those deliveries had been the cause
of lack of supplies on the frontline now
we're being told we don't even have the
supplies so it's really difficult
because we're not being given clear
information doctors are going in to work
every day just not knowing whether they
will have the equipment to protect them
and remember this is you know we are
talking about particular equipment that
is life-saving for for doctors and for
the patient's they care after we've been
talking a lot in the program about
whether the UK responds to coronavirus
has been slow you on the show a month
ago when you said that we don't have the
luxury of time to prepare for this
crisis anymore do you think those
earlier warnings from people like
yourself have been listened to well look
the evidence for us is that we haven't
been as agile or the government hasn't
been agile as it should have been about
two weeks ago I wrote an open letter to
the government are calling for a massive
ramping up of domestic manufacturing
capacity because we were getting at the
BMA and I was getting even as a GP large
numbers of of contacts from people
saying they're willing to manufacture
equipment schools have been supplying us
with high protection for example when in
fact
our GP practices 2/3 of them have
received no protection from the
government so we we've sent about 70
contacts many of them were contacts
known by doctors themselves so I can
vouch for the veracity and they've come
back to us saying they've hit a brick
wall and haven't had those contacts
followed up so you know we made it clear
weeks ago that we needed to do something
about the likelihood of a reduction or a
lack of protective equipment and even
now I mean I urged in my open letter to
leave no stones unturned we should also
be participating and we should have
participated in the EU stockpile we're
still part of that arrangement in the
withdrawal agreement we didn't do that
so I do feel that even now the
government needs to pull out all the
stops to do absolutely everything all of
those contacts we've sent and others
have sent need to be followed up because
because the public the population
deserve it and health care deserve to be
protected